help tear you I didn't have to [ __ ] man
I I was peeing sitting down
alright that's there we had a guest who
came here and he came in and I'm like if
he was gonna do the podcast and he just
goes he walked in I'm talking on the
bathroom day and he just sat down I just
hear shitty morning I'm getting the [ __ ]
out of here
I'm not staying here while you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like without announcing it yeah it is
very strange
yeah you gotta be like I'm gonna take a
[ __ ] I'll kill mouth or giulio style me
in there I'll drop it along that well
and there's a calm you know you don't
come really gonna celebrity poo yeah
it's not cool man cool no she gets out
goes to the Mexican restaurant he gets
as you know I thought you don't wanna
eat tonight you stay too bad you stay
you know what you staying here warm the
car one in the car I'll have my
assistant bring the refried beans you
eaten tonight yeah and she just she just
dumps all [ __ ] instead don't stead I de
Department oh I [ __ ] he has seen a
huge bowl of refried beans yeah oh you
talk about the Oprah challenge so he's
that's no bridge owns and then they sit
in the car did she go detention with if
you fed no this is what she does she's
not mad Oprah challenge of here man you
gotta sit in a hot car no he's seeing
that black Lincoln Navigator there's a
huge bowl of refight beans but some ass
cheese on top she delivers him goes I
dare you not to finish this and then I
double dare you to fart in my house I
meet this and then I [ __ ] dear Easter
and he's like who's gonna shut the [ __ ]
up here with your hands get in the
bedroom right now she's right behind him
and what's this what's now get on the
covers now and get on covers now you
gotta sleep if dear you're Dutch up in
this thing if there is a little peep out
your butt I'd wear a cork if I were you
put the cork in put the cork in
otherwise smite Tommy soap two weeks
two
you know are you going in this darkness
she rewards him with a long fart breathe
that in let me sleep - whistle it wasn't
any [ __ ]
and guess what tomorrow you're doing the
same [ __ ] thing and maybe you talk
about your [ __ ] college basketball
days all right and it's just the [ __ ]
Miss Lee she'll come in and shut our
whole podcast down what happened oh I'll
pretend like you're content Chin's
hanging from a bridge like what happened
she did leave some for you in the lobby
just a bullet and core to quarks - of
course I do you know what to do you know
did you mention this course on our butt
crying you time a doubler challenge we
eat a bunch of beans try not to fart
well boys I gotta fart so you guys are
gonna breathe it in [ __ ] dan is just
addressing the rumors that the UFC is
not doing well and he goes on to say
that they're doing really well
he says WME IMG bought us for four
billion and obviously they needed
certain certain numbers - for the banks
but he's spending another million right
now on another wing of that UFC
headquarters yeah and then Ari Emanuel
is you know Dana is holiday for another
wing there and then Ari Manos buying a
building next door so you go this won't
mean [ __ ] we're still growing
it's a mean [ __ ] I know rappers you have
seven cars they're dead bro what's your
point another one this one started
pretty trippy to me he goes who can
offer you a better deal than me in
combat sports [ __ ] boxing MMA whatever
it is who can offer a better deal than
me the answer is nobody this is what we
do keep doubting us he's right
so this is two parts here because he's
right as far as who can offer better
deal than me in combat sport
now when he says who can offer better
deal than me in combat sports
well let's branch off that no one he's
right
no one can offer a better deal in him if
you're a star this again
yeah with him the word yeah so he's
again he's right with this stuff but
when he says who can offer better deal
than me in combat sports
he's um percent correct is there anyone
on this earth can offer a better deal
than what Conor McGregor has made you
know or then what Brock Lesnar Ronda
Rousey made no you're right sir no way
but you have to be one of them now if
you're a middle tear guy and goes who
can offer your better deal than me and
combat sports uh basically everybody
it's pretty pretty even I can go to
Bellator at least I keep my sponsors the
pay is pretty similar but he's right
there number one by far as far as
offering better deal there's no one even
close in MMA for sure but boxing you
know when they get like hundreds of
millions of dollars who but see but
here's the problem
who gets hundreds and millions of
dollars who that one yeah you talk about
Floyd Mayweather like for wouldn't yeah
but yeah this it's the same it's all the
same pop boxing right and dies off their
pay-per-view stars but there's but they
also when they get big enough they have
their own corporations they've grown you
know promotions and that's when they
make this serious money but when people
say all these guys makin hundred million
dollars no they're not triple G's you
know regards one of the best in the
world if you know top three even though
Yost canal for debate whatever he only
made I think what five six million is
that's fine Canella made uh maybe
another eight million ten million but
they're you know
Connors making more money than those
guys and we started on the ground and he
took my and you know it's not even
jiu-jitsu it's just a [ __ ] homosexual
move yeah he took my head and had those
big packs those tan pecs they're all
greased up and sweaty and just went Iggy
oh my [ __ ] nose
yes Rd like go out and I tapped I was so
embarrassed
cuz my friends were all laughing there
is definitely he was a monster ones
strongest guys I've ever
oh he looked like he never stopped
breastfeeding no I know I did he [ __ ]
him with my nose it was so embarrassing
I thought maybe this morning for me
after that you know dude I would just be
so afraid if I could never fight like
you guys did man I'll just be so afraid
I would just honestly defecate on myself
or that I would just immediately break
my neck I got a really lean esophagus to
and I would get choked out easy I'm just
scared of it dude
I wonder what Ron's doings you get more
scared if you're fighting a black guy or
white guy do you feel like no I don't
care I don't discriminate I know it's
not not discrimination but just is there
any different so it's not a choice
you're making but it's like a different
fear that comes up no I think as I grew
up competing against but like my
neighbors your family box that's what
I'm used to
yeah it makes sense you know if you're
fighting a Russian or Croatian you have
your hands full you're not gonna quit
Russians are there certain guys you can
fight white and bike you know not
Russians aren't white but you know I'm
saying like an American white guy yeah
the American black every fighting them
maybe you might see a little quitting
and when the going gets rough you
fighting a Russian though or like an
African mm-hmm yeah they don't quit you
better bring your your lunch box
yeah Russian yeah I mean I can't even
those kids are [ __ ] over there
playing with stone dolls dude my buddy
told me that they had a dog oh yeah
children playing with stone dolls the
girls a dolmen had a [ __ ] quikrete or
something like those kids are there's no
water there's it's [ __ ] crazy
how's my boy what about um who's that
guy [ __ ] uh ready when you are bro
trying to think of his name there John
Joyner is that a fighter John Jones John
Jones you know I it sounds like you
might we might be seeing him sooner than
we thought
I said I'm talking so saying he you
might've accidentally took the stuff he
did so he might just get a year
suspension how do you accidentally take
note snorting cocaine and some [ __ ] was
laced in there okay what cocaine oh hey
look
yeah [ __ ] was it Nick okay yeah I think
the cocaine was laced with some sort of
[ __ ] some uppers trauma bones and [ __ ]
deca
Dianabol did i were one time we snuck
back some [ __ ] Winstar something cuz
they only have three steroids you know
what like deca went strong with the
other past [ __ ] test you 5,000 do one
of my buddies his skull grew and that
was it
not joking this is one our town named
Jean you look like Jean look like Bobby
big wheels
dude he came back to school the next
year he really had [ __ ] five four
extra pounds of skull and sternum on him
and that's it nothing else grew but we
stole a bunch from Cancun one time
enough shampoo bottle brought it back
still dispersed it and everybody used to
win strong but he'd be doing a bucket
you'd be doin chest press and [ __ ]
two bubbles would just pop out of your
[ __ ] chest it was fun man my buddy
and I used to do it man it was I just
wanted to be jacked yeah this one I was
so skinny man I just felt so you want to
feel powerful I wanted to feel some type
of power and did it work yeah
made me feel good I'm are walking
through class one time is there any like
throwback Thursday pics of you or
anything
I like a probably fine time man fine
please send it to me yeah I will I'll
find something I'll put something up
good and reject oh dude I was [ __ ]
jack bro and I had the [ __ ] best body
odor to kind of [ __ ] that would bring
[ __ ] over you know really yeah
nothing to Hardy but almost kind of like
a [ __ ] just like a homey kind of soup
brewing oh I won't like like it like a
Brad Pitt from Fight Club vibe I think
it was a little more French coming out
of me oh I feel like something a little
more like a little more ethnic
kind of like the potpourri but you would
see it a black person's house
yeah yeah I get a surprise you yeah it's
got some maybe some rose petals in there
but it so also might have some some stay
comes you know a couple of [ __ ] cuts
of steak comes in there